[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راوي القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعون
[موسيقى]
اسرائيل تستعد للرد على الهجمات من لبنان
وسط تحذيرات من تصعيد خطير
سامر
بان مقاتليه يتكبدون خسائر كبيره في
اوكرانيا ويؤكد ان قوات كياف صاعده
مع الصين عبر ماكرون وافندر لاين اتفاقيات
اقتصاديه وتقارب في المواقف من اوكرانيا
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
[تصفيق]
الفرنسيه الى الشارع اشتباكات واعمال
تخريب بعد فشل المفاوضات بين الحكومه
والنقابات
[تصفيق]
من اخر تطورات الوضع الميداني والتوتر
الامني على الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل
الذي لا يزال متواصلا لينذر بالمزيد من
التصعيد عشرات الصواريخ اطلقت من الاراضي
اللبنانيه باتجاه اسرائيل عدد الصواريخ
وصلت الى 34 صاروخا اسقط الجيش الاسرائيلي
25 منها عبر منظومه القبه الحديديه فيما
سقطت تسعه صواريخ بمناطق عده تسببت باصابه
اسرائيليين اثنين ردا على ذلك قصفت
اسرائيل اطراف بلدتي لقليل والمعلي في
قضاء صور جنوبي لبنان بالمدفعيه الثقيله
وفق الوكاله الوطنيه للاعلام وهي المنطقه
التي اطلقت منها صواريخ الكاتيوشا كما
لفتت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه الى اغلاق
المعابر من حيفا حتى الحدود مع لبنان
واغلاق المجال الجوي شمال اسرائيل وفي وقت
نف حزب الله علاقتها باطلاق الصواريخ
اشارت التقييمات الاسرائيليه الامنيه الى
وقوف فصائل فلسطينيه خلف الامر مشدده على
ان اطلاق هكذا هجمات من الاراضي اللبنانيه
لن يتم الا بعلم ميليشيا حزب الله
[موسيقى]
جماعه عم يطلع الصواريخ من عنا شايفين
شايفين من وين
[موسيقى]
ليكون من وين عم يطلعوا الصواريخ
وفي ردود الفعل طلب وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليه قياده اركان الجيش بالدراسه
جميع الخيارات الممكنه للرد على القصف
الصاروخي الذي تعرضت له البلاد ونقلت
وسائل الاعلام محليه نقلا عن مصدر مطلع ان
جلن تعقد اجتماعا مع مسؤولين عسكريين كبار
في اعقاب تعرض اسرائيل لهجوم نفذ بعشرات
الصواريخ مما اسفر عن اصابه ثلاثه اشخاص
هذا واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي استعداده
لمواجهه اي تهديد وذلك عقب اطلاق صواريخ
من لبنان صوب شمال البلاد وقال متحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه هناك عمليه تقييم
امني بشان اطلاق الصواريخ من لبنان كما
اضاف الجيش الاسرائيلي ان حماس اطلقت
الصواريخ من لبنان واكد انه يحقق في دوري
ايران في اطلاق الصواريخ وابدا جاهزيته
لجميع السيناريوهات في الميدان
طلبت قوه الامم المتحده المؤقته في لبنان
اليونيفيل جميع الاطراف باتخاذ اجراءات
لخفض التصعيد على الحدود بين لبنان
واسرائيل وقالت ان الوضع الراهن في جنوب
لبنان خطير جدا ودعت جميع الاطراف الى
تجنب التصعيد واكدت انها على تواصل مع
الجانبين الاسرائيلي واللبناني لبحثي
التطورات
من جهاته قال الجيش اللبناني انه عثر على
منصات صواريخ وعدد من الصواريخ المعده
للاطلاق في محيط بلدتيز بقين والقليلي
جنوبي لبنان ويجري العمل على تفكيكها كما
اكد الجيش اللبناني انه يسير دوريات مكثفه
في الجنوب بالتعاون مع قوات اليونيل
ابرز المواجهات عبر الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه
نهايه حرب تموز يوليو 2006 ارصد قواعد
الاشتباك بين اسرائيل وحزب الله
الخامس والعشرون من اغسطس 2019 سقوط
طائرتين مسيرتين اسرائيليتين في ضاحيه
بيروت الجنوبيه
الاول من سبتمبر 2019 حزب الله يرد بعمليه
عسكريه استهدفت اليه عسكريه بمستوطنه
اسرائيليه اعقبها قصف اسرائيلي لمناطق
حدوديه
السابع والعشرون من يوليو 2020 اسقاط
مسيره اسرائيليه جنوب لبنان والمدفعيه
الاسرائيليه تطلق قذائف على مناطق لبنانيه
حدوديه
الاول من فبراير 2021 حزب الله يسقط مسيره
اسرائيليه فوق بلده جنوبيه
[موسيقى]
مايو 2021 اطلاق صواريخ من لبنان باتجاه
شمال اسرائيل ثلاث مرات والقوات
الاسرائيليه تقصف مناطق حدوديه لبنانيه
الخامس من اغسطس من عام 2021 الطائرات
الاسرائيليه تقصف مواقع في جنوب لبنان ردا
على اطلاق صاروخين من الاراضي اللبنانيه
[موسيقى]
وينضم الينا من الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي
اهلا بك معنا زياد يعني اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي تقول بانه التقييم الامني
الاولي هو ان هجوما في غزه ولبنان سينفذ
الليله
هذا صحيح وهذا ما نقوله منذ ساعات الظهر
عمليا هذا التقييم الاسرائيلي لم يتغير في
الساعات الاخيره
لانه من الواضح بان اسرائيل
تبدو وكانها تصر على اتهام حماس باطلاق
الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان
وطبعا بالامس كان اطلاق صواريخ من قطاع
غزه بالتالي هي تخطط هذه الليله ربما لا
نعرف ان كان من ناحيه الجداول الزمنيه ان
كان طبعا لا معلومات حاليا ولكن التوقعات
ان تكون هناك غارات على قطاع غزه جرى فتح
الملاجئ في عسقلان وفي مستوطنات حدوديه مع
قطاع غزه وهنا ايضا على الجبهه مع لبنان
الامر ذاته عمليا هناك توتر شديد في
انتظار ايضا ربما
استهداف اسرائيلي لمواقع في جنوب لبنان
اسرائيل لم تطلق مدفعيه
ردا على صواريخ لم تستهدف بعد اللبنانيه
فقط ربما بعد انتهاء جلسه الكابينه
الاسرائيلي هذه الليله سنرى الى اين ستذهب
الامور ولكن بات واضحا بان اسرائيل عندما
تقول ان حماس هو المسؤول الاساسي عن ما
جرى هي تريد ان تقول نحن لسنا في صدد
الدخول في حرب مع حزب الله بمعنى لن
تستهدف اهدافا تابعه لحزب الله في جنوب
لبنان ولن تستهدف على الاغلب ايضا بنى
تحتيه تابعه للدوله اللبنانيه السؤال اي
اهداف تابعه للفصائل الفلسطينيه موجوده في
جنوب لبنان قد لا تكون مثل هذه الاهداف
جرى في السابق قصف مناطق مفتوحه
حرجيه في
مخيمات بعشرات المخيمات للفلسطينيين
لا ارى اسرائيل الان تقصف مناطق ماهوله
وتجمعات كبيره هذا هذا سيقود الى تصعيد
نوعي
هي سيكون على الارجح الرد في لبنان رمزيا
فقط قد يرد حزب الله ايضا رغم ذلك بعدد من
الصواريخ كما جرى في مرات سابقه هذا قد
يقودنا الى يوم او يومين من القتال لكن
الامور تبقى قابله للاحتواء وبالنسبه
لاسرائيل اسهل بكثير ان تفعل جبهه غزه لان
هناك وساطه مصريه وتدخلات يمكن ان يحتوي
الامر سريعا على عكس هذه الجبهه التي تبقى
مركبه من حيث معادله الرضع عمليا اسرائيل
تمتنع تماما عن الاستهداف في الاراضي
اللبنانيه ولهذا نفتح امكانيه ايضا ان
يكون استهداف لحزب الله ولكن في سوريا
وليس في لبنان زياده يعني كان اللافت هو
ما قاله الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه يتفحص ما
اذا كان لايران دور في هذه
الضربه الصاروخيه الامر الذي قد يقودنا
ربما الى ضربه في الداخل السوري هناك
علامات استفهام لانه معروف بانه الجبهه
السوريه هي الاسهل وليس هناك من رد فعل
يعني بغزه سيكون هناك رد فعل عكسي من
الفلسطينيين حتى بلبنان ضد حزب الله ايضا
هذا صحيح وطبعا التكادين لا ترين بيانا
عسكريا اسرائيليا يغفل كلمه ايران هذا
دائما موجود تحقق في امكان ان يكون دور
ايراني وما الى ذلك لكن الواقع حاليا بان
اسرائيل لا تريد فتح جبهه كبيره وحرب
شامله في هذه الجبه ولهذا هي ستكون حذره
معضلاتها هي عمليا في هذا الامر بانها ان
كان الرد هزيلا او لم ترد على
على ما جرى هذا قد يقود الى انهاء معادله
الرضا التي لم تعد كثيرا قائمه يعني في
هذه الجبهه الشماليه واذا ردت بقوه قد
يقود ذلك الى ايام من القتال وربما ما هو
اسوا ايا كان بنيامين سيتحدث ربما بعد
قليل للاسرائيليين قبل اجتماع الكابينه
قبل ان ينتهي عمليا هو سجل الكلمه والان
هناك اجتماع كبنت بعد قليل سيوجه كلاما
للاسرائيليين يمكن ان نفهم منه الاطار
العام لكن التوقعات هي بالفعل ان يكون
هناك تصعيد عسكري على هذه الجبه من خلفي
في لبنان وكذا ايضا في الجبل الجنوبيه مع
قطاع غزه المفارقه ستكون بان اسرائيل التي
تقول بانها تريد ان تكسر وحده الجبهات قد
تقوم عمليا باعمال عسكريه توحد هذه
الجبهات من خلال ردودها المختلفه ان كان
هنا او في قطاع غزه عمليا فقط نشير الى
انه في هذه المستوطنه طبعا تكادينا لا
ترين احدا نحن يعني انا والمصور وحدنا
لمده ساعات هنا ما اطلق لم يكن قذائف
مورتر على هذه المستوطن المطله الحدوديه
اطلقت ثلاثه صواريخ كجيوشه من عيار 107
ملم هذا اتضح بعد ان وجدت بقايا هذه
الصواريخ
اذا حدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه مدير مكتب
العربيه زياد حلبي شكرا جزيلا لك حتى
الساعه
اعلنت واشنطن ان حليفتها اسرائيل لها الحق
في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد الصواريخ التي تطلق
عليها من لبنان
ندين اطلاق الصواريخ من لبنان وغزه على
اسرائيل التزامنا بامن اسرائيل صارم
ونعترف بحقها المشروع في الدفاع عن نفسها
ضد جميع اشكال العدوان
دعا الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريج جميع الاطراف الى ضبط النفس وتجنب
اي مزيد من التصعيد بعد اطلاق وابل من
الصواريخ من لبنان باتجاه اسرائيل بحسبان
المتحدث باسم الامين العام ستيفان
دوشاريكا
نظرا لخطوره الوضع البالغه نحو على ضبط
النفس ونحث الاطراف على تجنب اي مزيد من
التصعيد
قبل ذلك اقتحم عشرات المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين صباح اليوم ساحات المسجد
الاقصى بحراسه مشدده من قوات الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اول ايام عيد الفصحى
اليهودي وبعد اقل من 24 ساعه على اقتحام
الجنود الاسرائيليين المسجد والاعتداء على
المعتكفين والمصلين داخله اقتحمت مجموعات
من المستوطنين باحات الاقصى لليوم الثاني
على التوالي بعد فرض قيود مشدده على
المصلين في المسجد الجيش سبق اقتحام
المستوطنين بالانتشار المكثف في باحات
المسجد مع ابعاد المرابطين من محيط المصلى
القبلي وكان اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه
للمسجد الاقصى قبل بتمديد واسع للدول
العربيه والاسلاميه اضافه لادانات دوليه
كثيره
نعم انا اعتقد ان اسرائيل في مازق جديد
على خلفيه هذا المازق الداخلي هذه الحماقه
التي ارتكبت في الحرم القدسي الشريف كانت
دافع عن اساسيا بالرغم من كل الحديث عن
ايران واذرع ايران ومخططات ايران وحسابات
ايران مع اسرائيل لم يكن يعني ذلك ليحدث
هذا الانزلاق الامني لولا هذا الاعتداء
المزدوج ليلتين متتاليتين بشكل لا كذا كل
غير مسكوك وهناك من يصف بالوحش على النساء
وعلى الاطفال والكبار والصغار الان المازق
الذي تجد اسرائيل فيه نفسها في هذه الليله
انها من جهه تريد ان تثبت لاعدائها انها
هي بالرغم من هذا الانقسام الداخلي هي لا
تزال قويه وتمتلك كل اسباب القوى للرد هذا
من جهه وهناك ضغوط في اسرائيل من اوساط
مختلفه في الراي العام وكذلك من داخل
الحكومات تدفع باتجاه الرد غير المتناسب
والقوي حتى
ولكن في المقابل هناك مخاوف في اسرائيل من
ان
النار الجميع يعرف كيف تبدا ولكن لا احد
يعرف كيف تنتهي وقد خبرت اسرائيل ذلك في
حرب لبنان الثانيه عام 2006 لم تخرج
اسرائيل لحرب شامل ولكنها تورطت بها ووجدت
نفسها في حرب بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه ولذلك
هي تخشى ان تنزلق الى حرب واسعه ما حزب
الله وما حماس ومع الجفتين الفلسطينيه
واللبنانيه وربما ايضا من جهه الجبهه
السوريه لذلك انا اعتقد ان اسرائيل ستبحث
عن جوله احاول فيها استعاده ما يعرف بقوه
الردع حفظ ماء الوجه ولكن ان تكون بذات
الوقت غير يعني
الدون ان تنزل الى حرب واسعه والى مواجهه
طويله ومكلفه لان اسرائيل قد جربت هذا
المجرب من قبل سيد وديع يعني بعد ليلتين
متتاليتين من الاعتداء على المصلين المسجد
الاقصى ما توقعك لما سيحصل الليله هل
ستستفز
اسرائيل ان كان الفلسطينيين
والجهات التي ارسلت رساله عبر الصواريخ
التي اطلقت اليوم من الاراضي اللبنانيه
باتجاه الاراضي المحتله
هل تتوقع تصعيدا الليله
عفوا هل تتوقع تصعيدا الليله في المسجد
الاقصى وان يتكرر سيناريو اليومين
الماضيين الليلتين المتتاليتين
انا اعتقد ان اسرائيل في هذه الجبل
التحديد ستكون اكثر حذرا مما حصل حتى تكون
يعني روايتها اكثر منطقيه ومعقوله امام
العالم خاصه وان هناك على الخط من وراء
الكواليس هناك مسائل لمنع الانزلاق نحو
يعني تصعيد خطير او نحو الحرب هناك جهات
عربيه وهناك جهات اجنبيه دخلت على الخط في
محاوله للحيلوله دون هذا الانفجار ولكن
وهذا طبعا يرتبط في موضوع سؤالك ربما هذا
يلعب دورا حاسما كاما في موضوع الحرم
القدسي الشريف خاصه وان ايضا الجبهه
الفلسطينيه محتقله واسرائيل تخشى ان يتكرر
سيناريو هبت الكرامه في مايار 2021 بان
تنفجر الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه وكذلك في
غزه وكذلك الاوضاع منثوره داخل اراضي 48
وكانت اسرائيل قد لخصت بالاجماع ان هبه
ايار 20 21 كانت خطا استراتيجيا فادحا بعد
سمحت نفسها ان في هذه المسند وان تكون
موجوده في حرب على عده جبهات ولذلك ستكون
اكثر
وليس بالضروره ان تصعد هذه الليله لا ضد
حماس ولا ضد حزب الله لا ضد لبنان ولا ضد
الجبل الفلسطينيه هناك اراء متساعده في
ضروره ضبط النفس والتريث ومحاوله البحث عن
مخرج لهذا
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من الناصره السيد
وديع وعوده الكاتب السياسي
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا بعد الفاصل وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تحبط محاوله التسلل مجموعه من
القوات الاوكرانيه الى دونيسك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نتابع تطورات الوضع في
الاراضي المحتله نتنياهو يقول منذ قليل
بانه سنضرب بقوه وسيدفع اعدائنا الثمن
وبانه ليس لدينا رغبه في تغيير الوضع
الراهن للاماكن المقدسه في القدس طبعا نحن
بانتظار كلمه
لنتنياهو بعد قليل حول الرد المتوقع على
الهجوم الصاروخي الذي تعرضت له الاراضي
المحتله الاتي من الاراضي اللبنانيه طبعا
تاتي هذه التطورات بظل التوتر الكبير
الحاصل بعد ليلتين صعبتين من
الاستهداف للمصلين بالمسجد الاقصى نتابع
هذا الملف فور ورود اي جديد
[موسيقى]
وقعت السعوديه وايران بيانا مشتركا عقب
لقاء وزيراي الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل
بن فرحان والايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان
في العاصمه الصينيه بكينا وجاء في البيان
المشترك انه تم الاتفاق على بدء الترتيبات
اعاده فتح السفارتين والقنصليات وكذلك بحث
استئناف الرحلات الجويه وتسهيل منح
التاشيرات للمواطنين كما تم الاتفاق على
بحث استئناف تبادل زيارات المسؤولين ووفود
القطاع الخاص اضافه الى تفعيل اتفاقيه
التعاون الامني الموقعه عام 2001 وتعاون
العام في المجالات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
والثقافيه والرياضيه الموقعه عام 1998 ودع
وزير الخارجي السعودي نظيره الايراني
لزياره الرياض وعقد لقاء ثنائي واكدى
القيام بكل ما يلزم بتحقيق امن واستقرار
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اقر مؤسس مجموعه فادنير الروسيه
بان مقاتليه يتكبدون خسائر متزايده في
الحرب في اوكرانيا هذه التصريحات
اتت اثناء زيارته لمقبره بها جثث مقاتلين
من فاجنر يذكر ان اخر حصيله رسميه للخسائر
الروسيه في اوكرانيا صدرت عن وزاره الدفاع
في سبتمبر الماضي تحدثت عن نحو سته الاف
قتيل من القوات الروسيه ولم تشمل الحصيله
المقاتلين في قوات فاغنر
كما اضاف قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه ان
القوات الاوكرانيه لم تتخلى عن مدينه
بخموت مؤكدا انها حتى لو فعلت ذلك فان
هناك حاجه الى مزيد من الدعم من الجيش
النظامي قبل محاوله التقدم اكثر
يجب القول بوضوح ان العدو لن يذهب الى اي
مكان لقد نظموا دفاعاتهم اولا في خطوط
السكك الحديديه ثم في الابنيه السكنيه
الشاهقه على الجانب الغربي وعندما يغادرون
باخموت سنضغط على كل واحد منهم سيتخذون
بالتاكيد مواقع دفاعيه حول
لهذا السبب في رايي ليس هناك حديث في
الوقت الحالي عن اي هجوم روسي
احبطت القوات الروسيه محاوله التسلل
للقوات الاوكرانيه الى دنيا حسب ما اعلنته
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وقال المتحدث باسم
الوزاره ان الوحدات الحدوديه بالتعاون مع
دوريات اداره الحدود اوقفت المجموعه التي
سمتها بالمخربه والتي بلغ عدد افرادها 15
شخصا والحقت خسائر بها دون وجود خسائر في
صفوف الجنود الروس
[موسيقى]
الملف الاوكراني كان حاضرا بقوه على طاوله
مباحثات الرئيسين الصيني والفرنسي في
العاصمه
باعاده روسيا الى رشدها والمساعده في
تحقيق السلام دائم في اوكرانيا الرئيس
الفرنسي اشار الى دعم الصين لميثاق الامم
المتحده الذي يدعو الى احترام وحده اراضي
الدول مضيفا ان غزو الرئيس الروسي
لاوكرانيا يهدد السلام والاستقرار
القائمين على المبادئ الدوليه الصين من
جانبها كانت اعلنت عن صداقه بلا حدود مع
روسيا قبل بدء الحرب في اوكرانيا الا انها
اعلنت التزامها الحياد ودعت الى عقد
محادثه السلام وكان الرئيس الصيني اعرب عن
استعداد بيكين لتعزيز الحوار السلمي
والتسويه السياسيه بالتعاون مع فرنسا
لدعوه المجتمع الدولي الى الحفاظ على ضبط
النفس في سياق الازمه الاوكرانيه
من الواضح ان الحديث عن الامن والاستقرار
يعني الحديث عن الحرب التي تشنها روسيا
على اوكرانيا هذه الحرب انهت عقودا من
السلام على الاراضي الاوروبيه لكنها حرب
الجميع لان احد اعضاء الامن في الامم
المتحده انتهك الميثاق وهذا غير مقبول
الفرنسي طلب ايضا من نظيره الصيني الضغط
على روسيا للامتثال للقواعد الدوليه
المتعلقه بالحد من نشر الاسلحه النوويه
الطلب الفرنسيه ياتي بعد اعلان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين في الخامس والعشرين
من الشهر الماضي انه سينشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في روسيا البيضاء جارت اوكرانيا
من جانبه قال الرئيس الصيني انه ينبغي على
جميع الدول احترام الحد من نشر الاسلحه
النوويه وعدم شن حرب نوويه من دون ان يذكر
الرئيس الصيني روسيا بشكل صريح وبحسب
الرئيس الصيني ستدعو بكين وباريس جميع
الدول الى منع استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
والبيولوجيه والكيميائيه وكذلك معارضه
مهاجمه محطات الطاقه النوويه والمنشات
النوويه المدنيه الاخرى
النقطه الثانيه التي قدمتها بقوه هي
الجديه والشعور بالامان فيما يتعلق
بالقضايا النوويه فرنسا تريد التاكد من
استبعاد الطاقه النوويه من هذا الصراع
ويجب احترام المعاهدات الدوليه ولا يمكن
باي حال من الاحوال نشر الاسلحه النوويه
خاصه في اوروبا وفي هذا الصدد يجب تذكير
الجميع بواجباتهم وخاصه روسيا التي اعلنت
قبل ايام قليله رغبتها في نشر اسلحه نوويه
في بيلاروسيا هذا يتعارض مع التزاماتنا
والقانون الدوليز
وفيما يخص علاقات الصين مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي قال الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده
مستعده للعمل مع التكتل الاوروبي لاستئناف
التعاوني على جميع المستويات ولضخ قوه دفع
جديده في العلاقات بين الجانبين واضاف
الرئيس الصيني انه يتعين على الصين
والاتحاد الاوروبي الالتزام بالحوار
والتعاون والحفاظ على السلامه والاستقرار
العالميين وتعزيز التنميه والازدهار
المشتركين جانبها قالت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
ان الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين شريكان
تجاريان ويجب ان يتعاون لمواجهه كافه
التحديات العالميه
[موسيقى]
على طريقه تطبيق بعدما تم اقراره في الشهر
الماضي في العشرين تحديدا من الشهر الماضي
واختارت الحكومه في نهايه المطاف تمرير
مشروع القانون من دون تصويت في البرلمان
بينما لم تتراجع المعارضه وايضا النقابات
التي تطالب بسحبه
[تصفيق]
ننتقل الى كلمه
في المسجد الاقصى سنعمل بقوه ضد المتطرفين
الذين يرجعون الى العنف بالنسبه الى
الاستهداف من الاجابات الاخرى سنضرب
اعدائنا وسيدفعون ثمن على كل دائيتهم
وسيكتشفون انه في ساعات الامتحان فان
مواطنين اسرائيل موحدين موحدون وان كل
الاجهزه الامنيه ستدافع عن دولتنا وعن
مواطننا شكرا وعيد سعيد
اذا استمعنا الى كلمه
نتانياهو حول التطورات الوضع حيث ان ندعى
الى تهدئه التوترات وبانه سيكون هناك عمل
بحزم ضد من يستخدم العنف وبانه ليس لديه
اي رغبه بتغيير الوضع الراهن للاماكن
المقدسه نعود الى تطورات الاوضاع
والاحتجاجات في باريس حول رفع سن التقاعد
وينضم الينا من هناك مدير مكتب العربيه
حسين قنيبر اهلا بك معنا الليله حسين يعني
تطورات الوضع كيف يمكن ايجاز هذا اليوم
كيف بدا وكيف انتهى
مساء الخير راويه قبل اقل من ساعه من الان
كنت في ساحه المواجهه بين القوى الامنيه
وعدد كبير من المتظاهرين حاصرتهم عناصر
الشرطه في ساحه
وهي تعمل في هذه اللحظات على تفريق من بقي
منهم عبر فرنسا تقول النقابات ان حواله
مليوني شخص اتظاهروا هذا النهار كما ان
عدد الذين تظاهروا في باريس وحدها بحسب
النقابات هو 400 الف فيما تتحدث وزاره
الداخليه عن عدد اقل من ذلك هي تقول ان
الذين تظاهروا عبر فرنسا هو
570 عددهم 570 الفا من بينهم 57
في باريس وحدها كان احد عشر الفا و500
عنصر امن واكبوا التظاهرات التي عمت انحاء
البلاد هذا النهار من باريس الى اليوم الى
مارسيليا وتولوز وكذلك نيس اوان وليل
وسدراسبور وبوردو
وعدد كبير من المدن الاخرى وتقرر اعلنت
النقابات الليله انها قررت تنظيم يوم
التحرك شعبي ونقابي واسع النطاق يوم
الخميس المقبل اي بعد اسبوع من الان
تحديدا في الثالث عشر من ابريل والتوقيت
مدروس كي ياتي عشيه القرار الذي سيصدره
المجلس الدستوري في الرابع عشر من هذا
الشهر ليحدد فيه فاذا كان قانون رفع سن
التقاعد يتناسب مع مواد الدستور ام ان بعض
بنود هذا القانون لا تتناسب مع الدستور
موقف المجلس الدستوري والقرار الذي سيصدر
عنه سيكون حاسما لناحيه تحديد اتجاهات
تحرك النقابي والشعبي الذي لا يبدو منظموه
انهم عازمون على التراجع شكرا جزيلا لك
مدير مكتب العربيه حسين قنيبر حدثنا من
باريس
نعود لتطورات الوضع في الاراضي المحتله
ونشاهد هذه الصور من قطاع غزه هي صور
مباشره فعليا نستمع الى الصوت الطبيعي
اذا
نتابع بانه نتنياهو منذ قليل كان هناك
تصريحات
دعا فيها لتهدئه التوترات وشدد على العمل
بحزم ضد من يستخدم العنف ولكنه شدد على
الضرب بقوه واجبار من يعني يهاجم اسرائيل
على دفع الثمن كانت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي
بتقييم امني اولي قالت بانه هناك هجوم
سيحصل ضد غزه ولبنان وسينفذ الليله
طبعا مشاهدينا كانت يعني كان الجيش
الاسرائيلي رصد اطلاق لعده قذائف صاروخيه
على جنوب اسرائيل من لبنان من جنوب لبنان
ولم تعلن اي جهه فلسطينيه مسؤوليتها عن
ذلك ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي اتهم حماس
بتنفيذها
طبعا لا يمكن الا ربط ما يحصل من توتر على
الجبهه مع لبنان
بالتطورات الحاصله بالمسجد الاقصى بعد
يعني ليلتين كانتا صعبتين على المصلين
والمعتكفين حيث قامت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه فعليا
باخلاء المصلين والمعتكفين بداخله
والاعتداء عليهم الامر الذي اسفر عن
العشرات من الاصابات والاعتقالات
طبعا كان هناك استنكارات
عربيه
ودوليه لما يحصل
الاراضي المحتله وتحديدا في المسجد الاقصى
وبانه
استفزاز لمشاعر الفلسطينيين والمسلمين حول
العالم
كانت اكسيوس نقلت عن مسؤول اسرائيلي بان
هناك بحث عن طبيعه الرد المناسب على اطلاق
صواريخ من لبنان
وكان مراسل العربيه افادنا بانه الملاجئ
في عسقلان ومستوطنات محاذيه لحدود قطاع
غزه قد فتحت الامر طبعا الذي ينذر بضربه
قريبه غزه حتى الان هادئه لا ضرب عليها
طبعا الساعات القادمه ستجيب على اي سؤال
الجمهوريون بمجلس النواب يستدعونا مدعيا
عاما سابقا في منهات ساهم ساهم في اطلاق
قضيه ترامب تابعونا بعد الفحص
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تواصل هيئه الهلال
الاحمر السعودي تقديما للخدمات الانسانيه
والرعايه المجتمعيه خلال شهر رمضان وتشارك
هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعوديه في خدمات
المعتمرين والزوار في مكه بعده مجالات
منها التطوع الاسعافي والانساني بالاضافه
الى التوعيه والتثقيف بعدد متطوعين يصل
لاكثر من 24 الف متطوع ومتطوع
[موسيقى]
ومن مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
اسامه قاسم اهلا بك معنا اسامه يعني ماذا
عن اخر الاحصاءات والارقام حول اعداد
المعتمرين والزوار الذين يزورون المسجد
حيث انت
اهلا وسهلا راويه تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع
المشاهدين قناه العربيه
طبعا عدد الزوار والمعتمرين الى يومنا هذا
وصلوا الى حوالي قرابه اربعه عشر مليون
زائر ومعتمر منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك
بحديثنا عن هذه الاعداد نحن نتحدث عن خطط
تشغيليه ثلاثه كل خطه تشمل عشره ايام
العشره ايام اولى اعلنت الرئاسه عن نجاح
الخطه التشغيليه التي امتدت من اليوم
الاول الى اليوم العاشر ثم ابتدات الخطه
التشغيليه الثانيه التي تنتهي في نهايه
العشر الثاني ثم بدايه الخطه التشغيليه
الاكبر خطه العشر الاواخر ادخل اترككم
الان في صوره مباشره عن امتلاء صحن المطاف
اليوم في الحرم المكي الشريف طبعا الان
انتهت صلاه التراويح بمكه المكرمه وهنا
الصوره امامكم الصحن ممتلئ بالكامل اعداد
الزوار والمعتبرين تزيد يوما عن يوم اخر
باعداد كبيره جدا طبعا بحديثنا عن الاعداد
المليونيه نتحدث عن خطه
في التفويج وادخال الحشود الى المسجد
الحرام اعلنت الرئاسه ايضا في بيان سابق
لها عن اهميه الابتعاد عن مواطن الزحام
واتباع ادوات السلامه وايضا الاستماع الى
كل مثلا الامور الامنيه التي تخص الدخول
والخروج من المسجد الحرام نشاهد الان ايضا
كل هذه الاعداد يصيرون وفق خطه تشغيليه
محكمه سواء في الدخول او الخروج طبعا
بحديثنا ايضا عن الهلال الاحمر السعودي
الهلال الاحمر السعودي وفر اكثر من سبعه
مراكز حول الحرم المكي الشريف يقدمون
الخدمات الصحيه والانسانيه والعلاجيه عدد
المستفيدين الى يومنا هذا وصلوا الى قرابه
سبعه الاف مستفيده ومستفيده من جميع
الجنسيات في خلال 14 يوما وخمسه عشره ليله
طبعا نتحدث ايضا عن خدمات المسانده
كالهلال الاحمر الدفاع المدني عدد من
المتطوعين والخدمات التي تقدمها الرئاسه
كتقديم مياه زمزم التي بلغت الى يومنا هذا
اكثر من 30 مليون لتر مقدم الزوار
والمعتمرين وايضا خدمات الامنيه التي تقدم
للزوار والمعتمرين هناك خدمات اخرى ايضا
سوف يتم تدشينها في الايام الغد القادمه
كخدمه التوعيه بالامن الفكري وايضا خدمه
الترجمه من قبل عدد من الروبوتات المتوزعه
حول مداخل الحرم المكي نتحدث ايضا عن
اليوم عن خمسه عشر مترجما موزعين على اكبر
بوابات الحرم المكي لارشاد الزوار
والمعتمرين الى مداخل الحرم المكي الشريف
وايضا انشاد في حال لو كان عندهم مثلا
تائه او احتياجهم الى خدمه ما كل هذه
الخدمات كما اسبقت راويه تسير وفق خطه
تشغيليه نحن الان في الخطه الثانيه مقبلين
ايضا على خطه تشغيليه اكبر في العشر
الاواخر التي ستشهد ايضا ازدحاما اكثر
وتوافدا لعدد من الزوار والمعتمرين اكثر
طبعا راويه احنا نتكلم اليوم عن اعداد
كبيره ومع ذلك لم تؤثر هذه الاعداد على
مستوى الخطه التشغيليه ولا حتى مستوى
الخطه الامنيه وهذا بالتاكيد يحسب شؤون
الحرمين جميع الجهات المسانده السعوديه
ايضا قدمت الدعم الكامل في هذه الفتره
للحجاج والمعتمرين لكي ينعموا بهذه
التجربه وايضا ان يحصلوا على تجربه ثريه
من خلال وصولهم ايضا الى ساحات المسجد
الحرام وصحن المطاف وجميع الاماكن
الموجوده في الحرم المكي الشريف وحتى خارج
الحرم المكي الشريف هناك عدد من البرامج
عدد ايضا من الاشياء التي تقدم للزوار
والمعتمرين سواء في اماكن اقامات محتم
بالنظر الى توجههم الى مناطق تاريخيه
واثريه وحتى مياه زمزم والخدمات التي تقدم
لهم كالايوان ايضا وجبه افطار الصائم التي
توزع حتى في مساكنهم كل هذه الخدمات ليخرج
هذا الموسم موسم العمره لهذا العام بموسم
استثنائي وكبير جدا بالنظر الى الاعداد
الكبيره التي تصل الى الحرم المكي شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا اسامه قاسم من مكه المكرمه
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا نشاهده هذه الصور المباشره من
غزه حيث منذ قليل يعني اعلنت القناه
الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه فتح الملاجئ في
مناطق جنوب تل ابيب نذكر بانه المصلين
الالاف يعني اكثر من 30 الف مصلي ادوا
صلاتي العشاء والتراويح بالمسجد الاقصى
دون اي اعتداء عليهم يعني يجب التنويه الى
هذه النقطه كان هناك حديث
لنتنياهو دعا فيه الى تهدئه التوترات
وعدم الرغبه بتغيير الوضع الراهن بالاماكن
المقدسه طبعا هناك توقع بضربه ورد فعل
عسكري على الهجوم الصاروخي الذي تعرضت له
الاراضي المحتله
المكان سيكون توقعات بان يكون غزه وايضا
لبنان
[موسيقى]
وقوف ترامب امام قاضي الجنايات في نيويورك
وخروجه بكفاله لم يعد مجرد حدث غير مسبوق
في تاريخ امريكا ترامب دخل معركه قانونيه
طويله نتائجها قد ترسم مستقبل امريكا
السياسي في السنوات المقبله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
المواجهه دخلت المحاكم وكل ما يسعى اليه
الدفاع ترامب الان هو تاجيل الحكم الى ما
بعد الانتخابات للقضاء راي اخر مدعم من
حاتم العام ينوي غلق القضيه قبل
الانتخابات وهنا يدخل ترامب نفقا بمخرجين
براءه او حتى ادانه دون ايداع قد يقوده
للبيت الابيض
ومصير اخر تفرضه ادانه مع ايداع الفوري في
السجن وهنا نهايه طموحاته السياسيه
استدعى الجمهوريون بمجلس النواب مدعيا
عاما سابقا في منهات ساهم في اطلاق قضيه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دون التروم وتم
استدعاء مارك بوميرانس وهو احد كبار
المدعين العامين في منهات الذين حققوا مع
الرئيس الامريكي السابق وكان جزءا من
محاولات مكتب المدعي العام في منهات لرفع
دعوه ضد ترامب لكنه استقال في فبراير 2022
حيث قرر المدعي العام
براج عدم توجيه الاتهام
نساء فاتنه لكنهن قد يطحنا بعرش واحد من
اقوى رجال العالم في لحظات ترامب في مازق
مع قصصه الغراميه السابقه
نجمه مجله
تقول انها تلقت 150 الف دولار مقابل صمتها
عن علاقه غراميه
خرجت ستورمي دانيالز لتدعي انها تلقت 130
الف دولار لاخفاء علاقه جنسيه بترامب فهل
صحيح ان ترامب كان زيرا نساء ولديه الكثير
من القصص هذا ما تحقق فيه المحكمه وما قد
يحدد مستقبل ترامب السياسي
لم افكر ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث
في امريكا ولم اعتقد ابدا انه يمكن ان
يحدث الجريمه الوحيده التي ارتكبتها هي
الدفاع بلا خوف عن امتنا من اولئك الذين
يسعون الى تدميرها منذ البدايه تجسست
الديمقراطيون على حملتي تذكر ذلك لقد
هاجموني بتهم من التحقيقات الاحتياليه
زوجه ترامب عارضه الازياء السابقه ميلانيا
لا يبدو انها سعيده بقصص زوجها مع النساء
وان كانت غير مشبته في المحكمه حتى اللحظه
غيرتها وربما اشياء اخرى دفعتها للاختفاء
عن الاضواء وعدم الظهور بجانب زوجها في
محنته الحاليه
تواصل الدفاع عن والدها وتنفي عنه عده تهم
منها التحرش الجنسي يواجه ترامب 34 تهمه
نفاها كلها في محكمه نيويورك منها تهم
فساد ومنها تهم احتيال ونساء قد يكون
كيدهن سببا في وضع اقوى رجال العالم خلف
القضبان
[موسيقى]
توقعت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان ترفع حالات
الطوارئ المرتبطه بفيروس كورونا هذا العام
ولم يحدد المدير العام للمنظمه اطارا
زمنيا محددا الا ان المنظمه ستعقد اجتماعا
للجنه الخبراء في مايو القادم
[موسيقى]
تمثل المشاريع الصغيره لبيع الوجبات
الخفيفه والمشروبات مصدر الرزق الوحيد
لكثير من اليمنيين لتوفير متطلبات شهر
رمضان وتنتشر عشرات العربات في الاحياء
لتوفير ماكولات سريعه وخفيفه للصائمين
وبيعها باسعار مخفضه
[موسيقى]
في عربه صغيره يقوم عبد السلام بتجهيز
انواع من السمبوسه والمشروبات وبيعها
للماره في احد اسواق محافظه مارب اليمنيه
للعام الخامس على التوالي ينفذ هذا
المشروع الموسميه مع حلول شهر رمضان
ويكسب منه قوت اسرته اغلق عبد السلام محلا
تجاريا كان يصرع فيه هذه الاشياء لعدم
قدرته على دفع الايجار ووجد الخير في
مشروع صغير لا يكلفه شيئا حاله كحال كثير
من اليمنيين هذا المشروع افعله بدايه كل
رمضان كل سنه هذا الموسم الرابع او الخامس
تقريبا واعتمانا اعتمادنا عليه يعني بشكل
رسمي ومصاريف رمضان مصاريف العيد وكذا
والحمد لله ربك كريم مشي امورنا سابره
المشاريع البسيطه هي الناجحه وتوفر اكثر
بحيث انه ايار المحلات غاليه بشكل كبير
فهناك ما بعض الانسان ما يريد ما يدخل
يوقع له دخل الا في رمضان من من دخل هذه
المشاريع الصغيره وتخفف عليه قبل موعد
الافطار تزدحم الشوارع بباعه الخضار
والوجبات الخفيفه الكل ينادي زبائنه عبر
مكبرات الصوت فطورك يا صائم
مشهد مالوف وتنافس بين المطاعم واصحاب
المشاريع الصغيره هذه التي يفضلها
المواطنون لانخفاض اسعارها ومسانده
اصحابها على الكسب والاستمرار قمنا بشوايه
في الشوارع ماشي معانا محلات
وخفضنا الاسعار من 4000 ريال في رمضان هذه
قبل المغرب بالذات لها طلب عند الناس
سمبوسه عصير
واشياء خفيفه وفيها الحمد لله مصدر ممتاز
الحلويات الشعبيه يجد سوقها رواجا خلال
شهر رمضان
وتنتشر عشرات العربات لبيع اصناف معينه
منها في ظل الازمه المعيشيه تمثل هذه
المشاريع قوتها كثير من اليمنيين في رمضان
وتعد مصدر دخلهم الوحيد محمود الحميدي
العربيه مارب
شكرا جزيلا لكم مشاهدينا على حسن المتابعه
طبعا ملفات العربيه مستمره وننتقل الى
الزميله ميسون وايد واخبار الساعه مساء
الخير ميسون مساء الخير راويه طبعا
ملفاتنا ايضا التصعيد الحاصل في اسرائيل
والقصف الصاروخيه من لبنان بانتظار كيف
ستكون الامور وتطورات على الارض فضلا طبعا
عن زياره الرئيس ماكرون الى الصين
والاحتياجات ايضا في فرنسا والعديد من
الاخبار الاخرى تفضلي
[موسيقى]